I attended an event and sat next to dawn
and Sam gold worm who run an amazing
company called 1229 they designed custom
scents for big brands and as they were
telling me about their work an idea came
to me I turned to them and said have you
ever designed a scent for a book have
you ever scented a book and they hadn't
and to the best of my knowledge it's
actually never been done especially for
adult books we set out together to
design a custom scent for together is
better and it's based on my personality
and it's the scent of optimism so of
course it begs the question all my
friends asked me well what is what is
optimism smell like well I can't really
explain what optimism smells like it's
not like lemons or patchouli or
something the way dawn explains her
process to me is that there are only
seven notes on the musical scale and
those same seven notes you can play
chopsticks or you could produce a
Beethoven symphony but it's the same
seven notes it's the same thing here
lemons or patchouli are simple notes
it's chopsticks what she has produced is
a symphony it is bright it is optimistic
it is sort of something special and we
produced it so that the first page is
infused with the smell so that everyone
can take in the optimism and it sets the
tone for the journey that they will
embark on when they read the book I hope
you enjoy it it really is pretty
remarkable
you